il oppose un squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur starz escaliers en français
si je pas d'inspiration pour tous de
cette vidéo et ben je m'appellerai
escaliers c'est parti ça commence des
escaliers très originale pour faire
simple un gros nez un journaliste
complètement foireux qui est à la
recherche de son prochain scoop et plus
précisément la recherche de trois
personnes qui ont disparu dans cette
[ __ ] d'usiné désaffectée et on veut
savoir la vérité et croyez moi on va la
trouver une fois qu'on aura la tête
coupée en deux à cause d'un monde voilà
c'est parti alors on est un long couloir
fin et glauque mais comme dans tous les
jeux d'horreur mais j'en peux plus
le jour où il y aura un jeu d'horreur
avec des choses mignonne beau avoir
marqué ce lundi le béa et et hobbies
est-ce que vous prendre quelque chose
ici y at il quelque chose de
collectables rien ils sont deux ils sont
là dedans oui oui avec mon index je
touche délicatement cette poignée de la
carène non mais je peux me montrer donc
voir où je me justifie à laisser les
choses comme ça je peux passer fermé ok
il faut rétablir le courant à tous les
coups et trouver le code il ya aucun
souci pour ça vous savez comme on est
doué e là dedans c'est quoi assez des
fonds c'est très bien j'arrive trois
jeunes gens ou alors je parle je fais le
scoop
trois jeunes se retrouvent piégés dans
une usine et des scènes au plat on a
donc un [ __ ] super réflexe sa part été
truquées ok on va se balader comme ça
toute manière de toute évidence ça c'est
une très belle photo à prendre ça à
temps mais c'est un grand regret sa part
est dix fois plus loin dans l'appareil
que dans le le hockey on se trouve dans
une grotte mec là mais relève toi c moi
c'est la fin tu trouves tu allais qui
voulaient passer la vidéo accroupissez
suffit à mon dieu un bruit nous devons
trouver la sortie
ou plutôt comment libérer nos amis qui
ne sont pas nos amis finalement qui sont
les coupables de notre futur meurtre
près des prix partout dans le mec juste
suffi quoi ta j'ai vraiment leur sens
que c'est pas loin par contre ça
s'énerve entamé je me perds et aux
marchés et aux marchés et à jallet dans
un nouvel endroit interagit avec les
portes et objets en appuyant sur eux
quand tu les regardes par exemple comme
ça ah ben voilà bien sûr au début où il
car ici la poignée fallu taper sur jma
au
voilà on a [ __ ] le jeu très bien une
vieille salle à manger avec absolument
rien dedans même pas des pis pour cette
lampe même pas une vaisselle fait rien
mais c'est honteux g à savoir tout faire
si jamais on glosait fuji quelque part
photo on sait jamais ça peut faire peur
aux mecs te tiens pas les photos qui
n'est pas sur son propre profil et
n'osera pas voudra pas se faire prendre
en photo ce qui est tout à fait normal
c'est une feuille d'or
on va faire fortune avec cette feuille
que la faible lumière d'espoir pour vous
tenir en haleine jusqu'à ce que la
lumière était tout fait que les
sanctions encore une fois ce stop
bon les gens qui t'ont dans cette mine
sur wallon la nourriture des monstres
qui est en péril leur permet de vivre
jusqu'à l'automne prochain et nous
réserve une mort lente et douloureuse
très bien merci pour cette anecdote
feuille de papier en or 1,9 à on
trouvera la feuille sur laquelle est
marqué le code croyez moi non mais les
gars ils ont
connaît on voit que dalle ton jeu c'est
un truc de dingue et vous croyez-vous
kreiner à revoir mais moi aussi en fait
un truc de regarder le match au talent
là bas c'est bien là bas c'est moi bien
là y'a quoi on peut pas on va sauter là
dessus un peu faire le tour une map
c'est une [ __ ] de blague c'est plutôt
banon mais les gars oh là là alors
archives archives c'est à deux c'est là
où il ya une porte et on est où il n'ya
pas le gros rouge avec moi qui vous êtes
ici là comme mot d'ordre toutes les
cartes de france bon va faire toutes les
pièces bombe à l'estec non moi j'ai pas
le temps ils ont fait une expérience sur
un sujet voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai
entendu mais ça me suffit je pourrais
être soir plus à un moment la peur est
présente alors ça suffit les conneries
tu es quoi ça je peux pas rétablir le
courant là elle d'une petite clé non
mais plus tard mais dites moi ce que je
dois faire la fin à mon avis ça va nous
mener quelque part il ya moyen regarder
la musique change à ça c'est bon signe
finalement encore un code je vais péter
un câble un salon n'avait pas drôle à
toucher quoi rien dire et à palabrer
qu'à paris on peut pas lui faire de
guinée je suis déçu d'avoir regardé goût
et ça marche regardez bien oui ça ça
ouvert saab en grillage été fermés et
oui s'en passe des choses avec cet
appareil photo j -cs à 20 mais quand
j'ai eu des frissons et toux mais mon
coeur est là deluca j'ai des frissons
ah bah voilà à au fait qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est mon appareil photo tu
me vendra pas un bon gars tu respectes à
pointe et aux îles salomon mais je me
permets tu sais qu'elle est là on a
trouvé le jeu m'a regardé lie à un
laboratoire secret pure est il une
nantes en papier a4 doré s'il vous plaît
pour me donner le code
ça doit être la chambre de sécurité avec
tous les codes alors là appareil photo
c'est vraiment une merde ça c'est fait
on a les codes de toutes les portes à
l'est on n'a plus qu'à quatre tout le
passé à toi y'a pas un petit plan avec
dans l'histoire j'aurais dû prendre en
photo le plan alors on va essayer tous
les codes
ah bah voilà [ __ ] ça faisait 20
minutes que j'attendais on y va on fait
comme si on souvenez du plan falloir
retrouver la salle où il ya le plan là
c'est le buzz mais il faut encore un
code afin d'en faire un aller-retour
jusqu'à alors fusé moi j'étais à celle
de sécurité de la chambrière elle ça m'a
réveillé encore une fois c'est bien mais
le matin mon réveil j'aimerais que ce
soit ça d'ailleurs voilà taper des
digicodes jusqu'à ce qu'un petit bruit
oh mon dieu c'est quoi ça non mais
attends mais qu'on voit pas encore plus
aller en profondeur quoi la fed devrait
se retrouver enfermé dans une pièce
en dessous la pièce où il ya les trois
étudiants or c'est génial on va mourir
tous ensemble dans d'atroces souffrances
n'ya rien nulle part même pas de
monstres en fait c'est ça il ya juste
des bruitages qui font peur de temps à
eau qui aiment pas y'a rien à mon dieu
oh non au nom alors là alors là ça c'est
un signe aux monstres un temps marc
courdés fois la salle de classe un peu
pareil donc finalement pas trop s'en
faire peut-être un petit con qui a fait
comme on court d'ailleurs qu'est lancée
à un truc là haut et ça détaché à dalle
voilà ait failli à caton nord à noël et
pas en or on s'en fout on l'apprend
l'aqua là dedans ça sert à rien il y a
rien ici en bas attendent ça fait dix
minutes que je recherche un truc puis
premier truc que je trouve dit que c'est
nul je suis scandalisée toi j'ai envie
de faire des additions sur ce tableau la
halle ça plus intéressant
eh ben on va rock oui mais oui what does
c'est la chambre de sécurité je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé mais je devrais aller
voir mais bien sûr qu'on va aller voir
c'est juste en haut à droite je m'en
souviens regard des eaux
le voilà [ __ ] le mans j'étais en train
de problèmes et il est juste olympique
ok je crois tout ce que j'ai dit sur
vols sur l'escalier
vraiment c'était peu voyez je vous
l'avais dit oui on fait attention en
salle de quoi ça peut peut-être aussi
sorti un stand propre qui sont là où le
matin je me chie dessus je me barre me
barre jean michel pas le temps c'est moi
m'en vais m'en vais je m'en allais
poteau où elle est sortie aux barres ou
à awala ya une porte qui s'écrie c'est
parfait régulièrement des portes secret
dans les murs ici c'est très pratique
box leur faire économiser un max de but
et mine de rien mais bien je suis de
retour cette [ __ ] de salles au foetus
comme ça à la richesse se sont mis en
rond c'est parfait bonjour l'échéance
comment allez-vous réunion d'alcooliques
anonymes aujourd'hui voilà la blague
facile mais bon je m'en fous ils à faire
pour me détendre vous avez pas empêché
de me détendre encore déchets des eaux
léchaient s'écarte merci merci je suis
votre roi le roi des chaises signaux
lâcher comme petit jeu c'est merci alors
on retombe sur qu au final doit pas
retomber sur cet homme quand même un nom
une fois ils en ont en profité pour
regrouper ses 7 coupes de cheveux
horrible tu te remercierai comme il se
doit
c'est à dire en donnant 10 euros comme
tout chez lui comme chez tous les
coiffeurs soit can yes on peut remonter
allons nous en dc avec notre nouvelle
coupe de cheveux dont je un oui dans les
bobines on voit là alors qu'est ce qu'il
ya ça doit être la chambre de sécurité
mais je sais je sais bien et alors on
fait quoi on va dans le conduit comme ça
comme ça on s'est bien rattrapé parlera
géant qui rôdent ici mais alors là du
coup on est on sait qu'on s'est
retrouvés ou en fait en fait j'ai
carrément reparti dans les mines quoi
mais je m'en fous j'ai les codes j'ai
les cotes pour déverrouiller la porte du
haut mont gao mondiaux une famille en or
je les trouvais et vous ne trouverez
rien que la mort est ce que vous
apportez avec vous entendez vous c'est
glauque
ça dégage mais je veux plus de feuilles
en or si c'est pour qu'elle me dise des
choses comme ça ça suffit à shaba voilà
on est au [ __ ]
je bouge pas mais ok je cours bien quoi
là-bas l'électricité mais ouais c'est
triste et c'est l'homme qui tenait à
cannes permet à part d un mois qui est
le petit con un chèque en particulier il
ya quatre bureaux 4 il devient quelque
chose de plus morts oui oui oui allô
quand allez vous hâte de tester une
chaise ou quoi c'est une cuvette et une
chasse dourges elle est là pour le coup
c'est là que j'invente rien je m'en vais
parce et marche et je vais ouvrir la
porte là haut les mains ça nord tu
verras jamais avec les grandes mains
avec un arrête arrête tu t'es quoi j'ai
fait de tes coindeau biatch lui casser
la nuque escaliers je me suis fait mal
merci pour vous d'un joueur à cette démo
technique et les nouveaux contribuant
sur kickstarter
oui mais là déjà je contribue à me
soigner cette bosse 1 qui pousse web à
l'agencé vient enfin de se taire un
petit jeu indé malheureusement je
m'attendais à mieux je vous avoue que je
pensais que on a tellement l'habitude et
déjeunera où il ya des monstres qui nous
poursuivent et où là on a vraiment des
raisons d'avoir peur que quand on n'est
d'autre que y'a juste l'ambiance qui
fait peur bon on est un peu déçu on est
gamin ça me regarde et n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo ça vous a plu et puis on
se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo je pense que m escalier en titre
simple énormément
donc je vous dise tiens tout le monde
escalier à les appuis sont plus petits
mais moi je suis fort donc je posséde
les plus grosses chaleurs donc pas cool